this is the call for pickup cleaning up
the small town of ours calientes to keep
safe the ruins above more than 1.6
million tourists visit the Citadel of
Machu Picchu every year camera ready and
their water supplies many like Felipe
Lopez don't know that much of the
bottles left behind used to end up in
the river I had no idea I always try to
recycle at home but I wasn't aware of
that problem
two years ago UNESCO threatened to
blacklist Machu Picchu racing the alarms
of high contamination because it's a
protected area the garbage has to be
transported out by train there are no
roads to reach Machu Picchu and the
wastes left behind was thrown into the
river dug into the ground or burned
endangering the Citadel and the flora
and fauna around it
since then municipal authorities began a
cleanup effort with the help of a
private initiative now they're
transforming more than one ton of
plastic bottles daily into compact packs
to be shipped out and a hotel is
collecting the used cooking oil for more
than 200 restaurants and hotels
transforming it into biodiesel reused in
cleaning before it also ends up in the
river the law prohibits the installation
of a large treatment site the tiny plant
donated by a hotel is treating the
organic residues in two by a carbon the
aim is to keep the nearly 5 tons of
waste here and turn it into bio carbon
that will be used for agriculture and
reduce contamination
officials want met to beaches
surroundings turned into the first
eco-friendly municipality in the country
but they say they need the support of
all tourists instead of carrying water
bottles municipal authorities say they
would prefer tourists bringing their own
reusable containers in that way they
could get rid of much of the plastic
trash water dispenser stations will be
installed around town in the meantime we
are promoting the no use of plastic in
hotels and restaurants and distributing
recyclable bags
everyone here is being asked to do their
part the change is low for now they say
machupicchu is being spared from this
danger Ariana Sanchez al Jazeera aguas
calientes peru